I am uh Nicholas with reason this is the
reason live stream I'm joined by my
colleague Zach weismuller hello say
hello Zach and we are joined today by
Renegade SEC commissioner Hester purse
uh late of the mercatus center she has
written a very interesting dare I say
blistering critique of a recent decision
by the SEC the Securities and Exchange
Commission a regulatory outfit that was
once headed up by Joseph Kennedy senior
uh way back in the day at its Origins uh
Hester purse commissioner purse thanks
for joining us
nick sack it's great to be with you and
I have to you have a disclaimer I gotta
start with my disclaimer which is that
my views are my own views not
necessarily those of the SEC or my
fellow Commissioners okay and you are
cooked to the gills right now right you
are flying on a mix of all sorts of
illicit drugs
uh no coffee but but that's about it
yeah and coffee is fully legal at least
for the time being
um we are going to run a clip uh until
what it uh coffee I'll say is is legal
despite the fact that the SEC might
start to regulate that after it gets rid
of the crypto uh security yeah you know
it it certainly is acting like one um we
are going to run a short clip by uh the
chairman of the SEC uh Gary Gensler I'm
talking about the Kraken decision and
then I want to come back to you and ask
you about your descent uh Zach can we
roll it put everyone on notice in this
Marketplace this really should put
everyone on notice in this Marketplace
whether you call it land whether you
call it earn whether you call it yield
so those other platforms should take
note of this and seek to come into
compliance do the proper disclosures and
registration and the like
so what uh chairman Gensler there is
talking about is a recent 30 million
dollar fine that was levied against the
cryptocurrency uh platform Kraken for
issuing unregistered or unlicensed
Securities because they were allowing
people to make money by parking their
cryptocurrencies at at the Kraken
platform you dissented from that fine
can you explain what was wrong with it
and why uh you think it should not have
happened
it's just the latest in a series of
enforcement actions where we're
seemingly
uh regulating the crypto industry
through enforcement rather than doing
the work of trying to sit down and
figure out where are the connections
with our Securities regulatory regime
and how is it possible for people to
engage in the activities they want to
engage in in a way that's compliant uh
and and instead what we tend to do in
these circumstances is just shut it down
and that doesn't seem like I mean that's
that is one way of protecting investors
from participating in something but it's
not a way of protecting investors
ability to make decisions about what
they want to participate in yeah you
called it lazy uh in your uh in in your
critique of it um Zach can you should we
put up the uh quotes for the the tweets
from
um I was going to say the the tweets
from Jesse Powell the head of Kraken who
um was saying like oh if all I had to do
was fill out a couple of forms as
chairman getzler seems to suggest in his
comments
um I would have done that um uh
commissioner purse is there I mean is
there a way right now for uh crypto
platforms to register with the SEC
well so there are there are a couple
different
um things there so this particular
enforcement action was around kraken's
crypto staking program and to the extent
that staking as a service
needs to be registered and that has to
be assessed on a case-by-case basis
um they could theoretically come in and
register with us but I think that's
where the lazy I was talking about the
institution being lazy we've got lots of
very hard-working people here it's not
the employees it's the institutions
taking the lazy approach because it
actually would require us to do some
work to figure out what a Regis what
registering a crypto staking program
would look like
and so it's not as easy as just
downloading a form from the from the
sec's website filling it out and you're
ready to go it would be a lot more
complicated than that
exactly there so uh we're going to be uh
after uh Hester leaves us today we're
going to be chatting a little bit with
the author of this piece Nick Carter who
has claimed that uh there's something
that he's CL he's calling operation
choke point 2.0 uh that's a reference to
an Obama administration era program uh
that was using the banking system to
crack down on certain industries like
payday lenders sex workers things like
this and uh he he's characterized uh
what has been happening in recent months
a lot of this coming from the banking
regulation side of things uh as kind of
a concerted effort across various
government agencies the FDIC and the FED
to basically deny
um banking Charters or financial
services to crypto providers uh there
was a recent uh just yesterday the SEC
proposed uh that they want to Bar
investment advisors from keeping assets
crypto firms uh do you agree that
there's this kind of
uh I don't know this concerted effort
across various government agencies at
this point to take a a much closer look
at crypto and if that's true is that
warranted or are there some dangers
um
in that kind of approach to things well
just as an initial matter I think that
description of what happened yesterday
at the SEC is a little bit simplified it
was a broader rule around custody of
investment advisors it does affect
crypto custody and it's an area I hope
we'll get some comment on
um I do have concerns about attempts to
try to wall off crypto from the
traditional Financial system a lot of
people in crypto probably find that
somewhat attractive but I think that
there are going to be touch points
between crypto and the traditional
Financial system whether that's Banks
investment advisors broker dealers and
so forth and I think what we need to try
to do is figure out how how traditional
players are able to engage with crypto
instead it does seem that the government
is take one by one saying no we don't
want Banks to do this we don't want
Banks to CR to to cut custody we don't
want investment advisors
to do this we don't want there to be an
exchange traded product built on bitcoin
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me
and I think we have to be very careful
this is the whole reason that a lot of
people are passionate about crypto
because too often the financial system
has been used as a way to exclude
certain people and let other people in
and
so I I really get concerned when
Regulators show up and they're favoring
particular uses or disfavoring
particular uses of the financial system
I think we have to be very careful about
that let's
um I want to ask you uh I I guess two
questions but first
um and one is kind of historical when
you talk about the institution of the
SEC being kind of lazy you know and it's
very clear you're not talking about the
people who actually you know work there
where does that where does that come
from
um where does that laziness or that kind
of predisposition against Innovation and
change come from and can it be fixed I'm
thinking uh you know a few years ago I
read a biography of Joseph Kennedy
senior the father of uh you know John F
Kennedy Ted Kennedy uh Robert F Kennedy
um and he one of the reasons he was so
instrumental in the founding of the SEC
is he you know he said plausibly uh you
know at a point when the stock market
was going to be regulated I know every
grift there is because I've pulled it
and I'm going to help you write and
create a system where it won't be gained
I mean is is it possible for the SEC to
not be kind of reactionary when faced
with new uh you know new kind of uh
financial instruments or opportunities
that are presented you know most starkly
in something like crypto particularly
Bitcoin
difficult for government agents
agents like ours to handle Innovation
well and I knew coming into this job
that that was an area I wanted I wanted
us to think about and kind of examine
ourselves to see if we were doing a good
job with that
crypto does as you suggested present the
question very starkly so what happens in
an agency like ours is you get used to
dealing with the same institutions time
after time they tend to be large
institutions that can afford to wait
while you think about their Pro new
products and services
and you're not used to uh people coming
in and challenging the incumbents it's
very hard to figure out how to how to
interact with them and so we're seeing
that with crypto especially because
you're seeing people who are not they're
coming from Total totally from outside
of the the financial system they're
trying something new and it is difficult
but I do think that we could if we made
a choice
to try to engage with whether it's it's
crypto product entrepreneurs or or other
product entrepreneur entrepreneurs we
could make a choice to do it better it
would certainly require a lot of work
and you know yes I have all the the
concerns
um about
governments trying to manage Innovation
that that you all probably have as well
um and and that's not the role I want us
to be in but I I do think that we could
try try for a fresh start and then more
oh go ahead Zach well I was just going
to ask you how do you think about
what the fcc's role is dealing with a
new asset class like crypto because it's
you know you're the Securities and
Exchange Commission and you you know
traditionally uh regulate Securities or
people you know Holding stock in a
company uh and cryptocurrency is a
little bit different and there's been a
little bit of controversy about you know
what even is a cryptocurrency there's
this ongoing discussion of you know
whether the SEC or the cftc which
regulates uh Commodities would be more
appropriate and then of course there's
people people within the crypto world
who don't want any regulation whatsoever
and then this issue with Kraken has to
do with not cryptocurrency per se but uh
staking cryptocurrency so you're using
these coins to these tokens to kind of
fuel the mining process and maybe that's
a little bit different than just holding
uh you know Bitcoin on a custodial
wallet how do you think broadly about
those questions and like what is
cryptocurrency and what is the sec's
role in managing it
I'm going to give you the the facts and
circumstances line that lawyers like to
use the the thing about the definition
security is a very broad it's a broad
concept and so we can touch lots of
different things that you might not at
first blush think involves the security
um so I think we just have to look at
everything on facts and circumstances
there is a question about whether and I
I've disputed with some of my colleagues
about what the definition of a a weather
crypto assets themselves fit within the
definition of security and it's probably
not worth going into that discussion
right now I think the question is are
there some gaps in Federal Regulations
where there isn't actually a federal
regulator and I think that's probably
true with respect to crypto assets and
with respect to crypto trading platforms
then you get to the question of well do
we think we need a federal framework for
that
I might feel one way about that I think
in light of some of the events of 2022 a
lot of people think yes we want to have
a federal framework then you have to
think about is the SEC the right
regulator
I think if you're going to set up a
federal framework the SEC could be the
right regulator for a lot of this
um but again that's really not our our
call to make that's congress's decision
yeah can I follow up on that do you uh
is there a sense that Congress is moving
to resolve that question I mean you know
in a broad scope and I know I think
everyone on this call has you know ties
to you know one way or another George
Mason University and and a critique that
emanates from that in economic and legal
uh critique of the administrative state
but is is Congress working to do that or
is this going to be something that
either the cftc or the SEC or somebody
in in the White House whether it's a
Republican or a Democrat uh comes up
with
there certainly have been efforts to
seeing some of those and I expect we'll
see many of them being reintroduced in
this Congress
the question of whether you can get that
across the across the Finish Line you
know it's difficult
um because a lot of the issues really
are quite difficult to to draft but but
I certainly think it's it's on the radar
of of people in Congress are you
comfortable though that I mean these are
the same cast of characters with you
know some minor additions uh you know
they've gotten rid of some old
characters and brought in some adorable
new Muppets like a long-running sitcom
but by and large these are people who
you know whenever somebody from a tech
industry shows up they hold up whatever
you know their game boy or their flip
phone or whatever and say can you help
me fix this I mean are you you know I
talked to Cynthia Lumis the senator from
Wyoming who's very bullish on crypto
um she said that you know the level of
uh even under knowledge of like you know
that it exists much less expertise in
crypto is stunningly small among her
elected uh colleagues
well as a regulator I think it's really
important that we take our guidance from
Congress because they are the ones who
are politically accountable and so you
know it's important for people who are
interested in this area or any other
area to be in touch with their with
their members of Congress
um but we really have to take guidance
from them and I wouldn't assume that
um you know one of the one of the
theories behind agencies is that they're
expert regulators and we do have a lot
of people here at the SEC with
tremendous expertise and Securities Law
obviously but also who know a lot about
this technology but still I you know we
can't design this without the input of
politically accountable is that um is
that point of view that you have is that
widely shared by your fellow
commissioners
I think so and mean I think we all
recognize who the boss is and it's it's
it's not us but but I I think one of the
things that you're seeing happen in this
area that's really causing me a lot of
concern is that you're having
regulations jurisdiction grabbing
through enforcement right if you plant
your flag with enough Enforcement cases
people start thinking oh well I guess
the SEC is the regulator or the cftc is
the regulator and that's why I really
would like for Congress to come in and
say no this is who we want to be the
regulator this is how we want it to work
I'd like to bring up this comment
because I think it represents the kind
of uh you know crypto Enthusiast point
of view on regulation I just like to get
your reaction to it Denny Hicks says I
don't think the SEC should be involved
in it at all this was founded on that
main idea to move away from any entity
controlling the monetary Investments and
transactions the group started Bitcoin
because they were wanting to have full
control over their finances without the
federal level getting involved and
taking their cut or making any rules and
regulations for it violation of freedom
and you know there's that that's true
that that is why that's why Bitcoin
was started that it's in the Satoshi
white paper and there's kind of the
inevitability that Regulators are going
to try to regulate you mentioned some of
the issues that arise there with uh kind
of they get comfortable with incumbent
firms and then makes it harder for new
entrants so this was all meant to
disrupt that whole system is there a
case for just saying okay if the SEC
wants to put out some sort of
registration form and make it optional
and let people who want to opt in to
only the SEC approved versions that's
fine but just let crypto be crypto and
people can kind of enter at their own
risk
yeah and I certainly understand that
point of view but I think we have the we
have rules on the books and to the
extent that whether it's crypto or
something else those implicate the
existing rules then we have to enforce
those rules now if you're talking about
do we want to develop a new regulatory
framework where there really are gaps
and where things really aren't covered
that's a conversation that we should be
having and I think one of the things I
always say is don't jump to the
conclusion that regulation is going to
be the answer to solving problems I mean
a lot of the problems we saw with
centralized entities in the crypto World
during the last year are problems that
are very similar to problems we see with
we've seen with traditional Financial
intermediaries but there also are things
that people can do on their own to hold
those intermediaries accountable and as
and as people working at intermediaries
they can do things to show people that
they're that that they're doing what
they're saying they're doing so people
in crypto shouldn't be jumping to the
conclusion that regulation is is always
the first and best answer
we have to have this conversation as a
community you know I'm maybe on on one
side of the spectrum and and saying look
let's let's figure out whether there's a
better way to do this but there are
other people who are very much committed
to having a regulatory solution and
that's just something in this in this
Society we got to work out and figure
out where most people are how much of
the sense of urgency that seems to be
kind of coursing through the SEC and the
cftc and and the federal government in
general is being driven by the Meltdown
of FTX
um and uh you know the uh the apparent
you know hypocrisy and kind of mendacity
of of uh Sam bakeman freed
um and can you uh I mean is that
um particularly the stories that point
to a very kind of cozy relationship
between SEC chairman Gary Gensler and
SPF um is that are are we in a mode now
where something's got to happen and
weirdly it's going to be you know the
the the pretext for that is going to be
dealing with somebody who is atypical of
um of the way crypto platforms actually
operate and before you answer I just
want to give the full context of of this
story here because you know we're not
pointing the finger and accusing Gensler
of anything necessarily this story is
just an example of the kind of you know
political pressure that we speculate you
know might might be on him this this
meeting that happened
um the reporting was that you know
Gensler was lukewarm to Friedman's pitch
um and wanted uh this is from Fox
Business any new SEC announced crypto
exchange to Mere standards of public
exchanges like NASDAQ or the New York
Stock Exchange so you know it's not
necessarily that anything wrong happened
there that we know of but I guess the
the question and correct me if I'm wrong
Nick is like is that political pressure
or you know what happened with FDX
meltdown driving decision making it all
within the SEC from your end and just to
you know let put another layer of
frosting on that um SBF we talked with
Jesse uh Powell of crack in a few months
ago and one of the things he pointed at
is that most of them major crypto
platforms which have been around for a
decade at this point or close to that
have come together on a kind of basic
code of conduct best practices FTX was
not interested in doing any of that they
were and they were not registered in the
U.S except to the bare minimum that they
needed to be I mean they were
headquartered offshore and they kept
going to the SEC and other agencies to
say hey let's do a special deal that
that pulls Us in so that's what I'm
saying where somebody like SBF is
atypical of kind of the bigger and more
established exchanges so you know are we
are we going to end up making
regulations about crypto based on
somebody who was a bad actor as opposed
to the you know the kind of uh more
responsible people at the at really at
the center of the industry
well I can't speak to
speak specifically we do we do Horsemen
case but I I'll say generally that the
events of 2022 confirmed the
preconceptions of many people
uh in the Washington World which is that
crypto is doesn't have any use and is is
not decentralized and is all about
uh defrauding people that's what some
people in Washington think I'm not
saying everyone does but I think some
people do
and that's why it's really important for
people who are in crypto to think about
you know applying the lessons from
traditional Finance right and thinking
about that thinking about you know if
you're really trying to build something
decentralized what does that actually
look like
and then sort of thinking about whether
it makes sense to say
let's try to carve out the decentralized
world and figure out whether and really
make the pitch that regulation is not
wouldn't play the same role there
because the decentralization the
on-chain aspects the fact that everyone
can participate on the same terms that
actually takes the place of Regulation
it's harder to make that case when
you're talking about large centralized
intermediaries that are holding people's
assets right so I think we can try to
make some distinctions but it's really
important I mean into the comment that
you read earlier Zach you know it is
important to think about
where are the spaces where people just
want to be able to say yes I'm opting in
to a less regulated space I'm certainly
open to something like that I don't know
whether you know others in Washington
are but I but I think you know everyone
goes in Eyes Wide Open you've made a
choice to operate in a space that has
less regulation than other spaces I mean
could you talk just a little bit about
the structure of the SEC for people who
don't understand it you know this
commissioner system I've read your work
on this I know you were actually an
advocate of that system and now as
someone who's you know inside of it what
is that like being you know on a Board
of Commissioners who you know disagree
on topics and and how does that form or
how does that affect the the ultimate
decision-making process yeah I mean
there are five of us and the chairman
sets the agenda manages the staff but
and and so we have less input on on on
sort of the rules that we're going to be
doing and so forth but we all all have a
voice and the idea is that you want to
have people from different perspectives
because you want to have some policy
consistency over time we we all vote on
every enforcement action and on every
rulemaking
um I you know people sometimes say to me
well how should you do nothing except
for talk about things so why don't you
just resign and I think the point is and
other people say to me well someone who
is a skeptical of Regulation as you are
shouldn't even be at a regulator and my
response is I think it's really
important to have people with different
voices saying we need to look at these
things from a different perspective and
um you know sometimes it takes a long
time to shift the thinking but I think
it's it's worth having people sort of
debating these things rather than just
coming out with one view I mean the
world is very complicated and there's
there's more than one way to look at
things we've got two questions for you
and we're going to let you go at 1 30.
um first can you building on that what
is your general theory of good
regulation in the financial sector um
you know as when you were working at the
mercatus center at George Mason uh you
wrote a lot you were a fierce critic of
sarbanes-oxley and Dodd-Frank uh the
last two Mega kind of uh you know pieces
of legislation on the financial sector
what does good regulation look like
um you know if you know if you were able
to write that well I think the first my
first principle is that if two people
voluntarily agree that they want to do
something there needs to be a very good
reason for the government to step in
into that transaction and say no you
can't do that or you have to do it
differently there are times when the two
people's agreement to do something can
have consequences for other people
outside of that transaction we have to
be thinking about that
um so my my gen that's my general
philosophy I I think we need to make
sure that people's incentives
um
are match up with consequences right so
if you if you if you take a step that's
a stupid step and you lose a lot of
money the government shouldn't be coming
in to prevent you from losing it
um and unfortunately that has happened a
lot in our financial system and it's
sort of changed the way everything works
and it's LED government to come in and
say Well since we're bearing the
consequences when people make stupid
decisions we're going to try to make
decisions for them but because
government doesn't have the right
incentives it's very difficult for
government to make decisions effectively
markets are much more effective at
conveying information than a regulatory
system is and so we need to capitalize
on that we need to take advantage of the
fact that markets transmit information
really well so that might my theory is
always yeah there's a place for
regulation but it shouldn't be the first
place we look it should be the last
place what what does a good regulation
or what what's an example do you think
of a good regulation that actually
reduces transaction costs without
distorting you know behaviors I think we
can play a role in helping people get
disclosure to make their own decisions
about things
um so and and certainly you know their
rules around mutual funds that I think
have been effective rules
um there there are a lot of things the
SEC does that I think do help reduce
transaction costs
but I think too often we try to just
jump in and make a merit-based decision
based on our understanding of someone
else's circumstances and I find that
really offensive
um this question we have on our uh
YouTube live stream people can pay uh
money to get make sure their question
gets asked so we always try to uh uh
honor that uh ganoush Dash get a stash
excuse me uh right I was reading about
how the web 3 Foundation worked with the
SEC I'm morphing polka dot from a
registered security to no longer a
security it became software can all
crypto companies come in and do that too
could you well I'm not familiar with the
circumstances of that particular uh that
particular question
yes people come in and work with the SEC
but I think one of the problems that
we've seen in the crypto space is that
people are not coming out when they come
in they're not coming out with a
workable solution to move forward and
that's what's so frustrating to me is
you can't just be all about enforcement
you have to say you have to show people
proactively that no you can actually
come in we'll work with you to meet our
regulatory objectives which Congress
gave us
but also to allow you to operate as a
business not to have you sitting in line
or in the waiting room for three years
as your funding dries up only to find
out that you can't move forward and
that's what we really need to work on at
the SEC that's what I hope we can do I
still am optimistic that we can change
our approach
commissioner Hester purse of the SEC uh
thank you so much for talking to the
reason live stream today thanks Nick
thanks Zach thank you
all right uh so we are going to be
joined in a little bit by Nick Carter
the uh investor Finance character and
Bitcoin uh Bitcoin uh bull
extraordinaire in just a few minutes
um and we're going to be talking about
his operation choke point 2.0 is
underway and crypto is in its crosshairs
piece at uh pirate wires the sub stack
run by Mike Solana which everybody
should check out
um Zach just uh your uh initial uh
feedback from or or sense of what
commissioner purse was talking about
yeah uh I it was interesting when she
was talking about this kind of this
comment she gets all the time about you
know what what's the point of you even
being there you're the one person who is
uh saying hey can we rethink these
regulations and you you know can write
your descents but but there's no there's
no action I thought that was really
interesting because it's I I mean I know
I for one am glad that there's at least
one person on the SEC Board of
Commissioners who's uh you know forcing
a kind of rethinking of that so
um yeah I I that that was one of the the
more interesting insights to take away
from that to kind of get a an idea of
how things work on the board yeah and I
agree and also just the you know I mean
like the her descent on the Kraken fine
uh was if you know the vote was four to
one she was the one again sense that
like you know it's better that it's four
to one then it's five to zero and who
knows uh maybe she will win over some
people her term doesn't end until 2025.
uh SEC Commissioners are
um you know they have uh kind of
overlapping uh uh stacked
um terms so that no one party you know
the idea behind that is that no one
president essentially gets to you know
fully install the whole board
um so that there is a plural you know
there's a there's differences of opinion
and then she was talking a lot about uh
or she talked a little bit about the
sort of relationship that inevitably
develops between the regulators and the
industry that they're regulating where
they just become more and more
comfortable with certain firms because
the the big firms tend to be the ones
that both are better at complying and
also kind of provide them with some uh
expertise on the industry and and that's
the problem that uh you know the
economist George Stigler identified as
be you call you know regulatory capture
basically
um and I think that is really at the
root of of what's driving
um the crypto at least that that's
that's not what's driving kind of the
crypto economy what's driving that is a
lot of it is frankly you know
speculation and people trying to make a
quick dollar but that that was at the
core of its Beginnings was to try to to
sever that relationship
um and you know right now I I was just
about to pull this up earlier
um this is the amount of value locked in
the so-called defy economy right now and
and you see it was peaking you know uh
close to the 200 billion Mark maybe I
think it was about 180 billion was at
its peak and then there was the crypto
crash and right now there's fifth almost
50 billion dollars you know locked in
this in this economy that
people characterizes as the wild west
but there's despite that being the case
despite it still being a relatively
unregulated space there's still like
like something is happening there and
some value is clearly being created and
um there's there's a dynamism there and
yeah like the the whole idea that
um that
people can kind of opt into it and and
know that there's risk to it and there's
these there's this volatility there's
these ups and downs and then there's the
outright frauds like or let's say
alleged frauds like uh Sam bankman freed
it's kind of like interest it's just
really interesting to watch this this
emergent relatively unre regulated and
now pretty huge Market develop and I'm a
little bit worried that kind of the the
heavy hand is just now starting to come
down yeah let's uh run through some uh
comments from Facebook as well as
YouTube Lawrence espinoza's how do they
pick and choose where to target uh that
would have been a great question for uh
commissioner purse
um but um you know I mean she intimated
the commissioner really sets the agenda
so it's up to Gary Gensler
um what are you know what are the
priorities and things like that but it's
like any regulatory agency I think where
there's a lot of different interests
that are pushing to say hey do this do
that oftentimes you know one of the
things and uh Zach you were getting at
this there's an idea that what
Regulators do is that they look at it at
the area that you know is under their
survey or their domain and they uh say
where are things bad and we're going to
fix that but in fact oftentimes what
happens is that they are working kind of
at the behest of the biggest most
established firms in an industry and
they are doing the bidding of that firm
where they might say hey you know what
like rule changes in this direction
would help us and you know why don't you
do that so that happens uh Vera s says
does the agency worry about the
increased risk of potential legal
challenges to it for its sub Rose of
Regulation by enforcement efforts
I'm not sure I understand that fully but
I think the SEC doesn't care they're not
worried about that nor is any other
regulatory agency occasionally they'll
get smacked down let me chime in on the
the earlier question about why was
Kraken specifically targeted
um and I don't know the exact answer I
see that Nick Carter just uh popped in
so you know maybe we'll Circle back to
that in a second actually and uh welcome
Nick into the stream can you hear us all
right yes sir yeah thank you all right
thank you for uh thank you for joining
us I see the mustache is back
uh so we uh just uh talked with
commissioner Hester purse of the SEC who
dissented from the recent fine that was
levied against Kraken and um you had uh
in a previous kind of online
conversation leading up to this you had
asked whether or not
um do you think she would uh distance
herself from the idea that the SEC or
any agency should try to essentially
rule out any particular subset of an
industry or a field she answered
affirmatively like that there's no
reason that any agency should be going
after a particular subset within a legal
industry which brings us to what we you
know want to start out talking with you
about which is your recent piece for
pirate wires the Mike Solana sub stack
operation choke point 2.0 is under Ray
underway and crypto is in its crosshairs
can you uh very quickly uh kind of
summarize this piece for us and start
off by talking about what operation
choke point 1.0 was yeah let's start
with that
um thanks for having me choke point was
a program that lasted from approximately
2014 to 2017 which involved uh
effectively ring fencing certain legal
but uh maybe distasteful Industries
um and other legal industries that maybe
you know depending on your perspective
were fine
um mostly under the Obama Administration
and instead of using Congress to set
policy or legislate
um the end around that was found was to
use the FDIC to pressure Banks to not
service these industries basically the
banks would pressure the payment
processors which would then you know
de-platform uh you know these specific
Industries and the ones in questions
were like Firearms ammunition the adult
entertainment industry
and a lot of other stuff uh some of it
pretty sketchy like payday lending and
things like that
um and you know what choke point really
characterized choke point was sort of
the informal nature so it was all about
insinuations and veiled threats uh that
basically Banks would be investigated if
they continued to platform these
particular Industries and that ended in
2017 when a few members of Congress
noticed what was happening they got
complaints from constituents
um and basically opened investigations
and and shed some light on the thing so
that was chokepoint 1.0 it didn't really
end though I mean um basically this
guidance was internalized and then
payment processors and Banks started to
incorporate these risk standards into
their assessments of who to platform uh
which
um you know meant that there was still
kind of an issue in terms of a lot of
these high-risk Industries being
platformed thereafter so what is 2.0
doing to put crypto and its crosshairs
now as the headline puts it
yeah so some people accuse me being
inflammatory with this but I you know as
a crypto person I'm seeing it on the
ground I'm hearing directly from
startups that they're being de-risked
you know they're not able to get Bank
access the standards for being able to
be banked are much much higher all of a
sudden so there is a concerted effort
now basically from the administration on
a cross-agency basis across virtually
all Bank Regulators in this country
really only recently I'd say last three
months and in particular in the last
month uh to sideline the crypto space
and deprive them of their linkages to
the traditional banking system this is a
multi-front attack it's happening
um in on a coordinated basis in fact the
coordination is very
clear because sometimes the same
guidance comes out from multiple
agencies and organs of the government on
the same day within hours so it's not a
spontaneous thing I mean clearly it's
coordinated and the objective is really
to you know the benign interpretation is
well crypto's risky and so we don't want
Banks touching it in any way because we
don't want crypto to have systemic
effects on the banking system that's the
benign interpretation the more hostile
one is well we just want crypto to go
away as an industry and so we're going
to deprive them of their linkages to
Fiat which which would eventually kill
the industry if it was successful and so
that that's on the banking side of
things and uh by the way we'll link this
and all the material we show in the show
notes so you can read uh Nick Carter's
piece in in full by just you know
following that link below but uh you
know we we've just been discussing in
the first part of the show The the
latest SEC actions
um do you see that as
part of this or is this just a totally
uh you know do you suspect there's some
sort of uh coordinated action you know
across the entire Biden Administration
um or is the SEC really you know a
totally separate they've got their own
thing going
um and also like how big a deal do you
think this action that was taken against
Kraken is in the big scheme of things is
that kind of a minor setback for Kraken
or is it like an existential threat to
the whole industry
yeah a lot in there
um so the SEC has been hostile to crypto
ever since well really under Clayton and
now of course under Gensler
that hostility is nothing new so it's
not entirely surprising that they're
going after cracking and staking I would
say the intensification is evident from
the SEC in terms of their oversight I
believe that they feel emboldened that
they have more of a political mandate
now to go after crypto post 2022 in the
FTX collapse so I think the same
undercurrent Trends are driving the
sec's action and the action of the FED
FDIC OCC which is feeling politically
emboldened due to a lot of people are
sympathetic with attempts to ring funds
through crypto space in the US after the
collapses of last year and also Congress
being deadlocked that's an important
thing that I think people are not
talking about is the prospects for
legislation here of any sort are very
minimal going forwards for the next two
years
I don't think we'll see anything
pertaining to crypto actually believe it
or not even though the house is somewhat
favorable so the agencies realize
nothing's going to come out of Congress
nothing's going to be done that way
they're going to be stymied let's say
the Biden administration at a crypto
crypto package they wanted to push it
they wouldn't be able to do that with
the house so now a lot of folks in the
executive branch are saying to
themselves while it's on us to regulate
effectively legislate through regulation
and that is absolutely what we're seeing
at the SEC they are interpreting their
mandate in a very broad way as is the
fed the FED is now growing their mandate
there's a little there's some wonkish
details in the January 27 chain of
events which I mean are probably worth
digging into but yeah I think that's
what we're seeing really is there's an
understanding in Washington now Congress
is deadlocked okay it's on us The
Regulators to do something can I ask
um you know when with something like FTX
clearly you know kind of the crypto
winter kind of sets the stage for more
regulation because you have a lot of
people who are probably going you know
either grousing to their Congressman or
you know there's a sense like okay you
know we lost this huge percentage of
whatever we had invested in crypto for
whatever reason and we're kind of pissed
about that uh this you know happened uh
you know after the uh the tech Bubble
Burst you know there's new stock market
stuff as a housing bubble bursts you
know there's new regulations
um with FTX
um really puts gas on all of that can I
ask you was is there something the
crypto Community should have been doing
to kind of unmask or expose or pull get
people to stop putting money into FTX
ahead of time or is there anything like
that is there you know what if if
broadly speaking crypto is going to be
something that is independent of
government and independent of Regulation
not not independent of risk but like is
there something that people in the
crypto space should have or could have
been doing more of to unmasked like to
squeeze out the the spfs of the world
before they get to a point where they
really threaten everybody Who's acting
you know in a positive way absolutely
without a doubt there's three things
specifically one is the investors need
to be better with their diligence quite
today a lawsuit dropped against Sequoia
and Paradigm the lead investors in that
FTX deal alleging that they failed in
their diligence and in fact they sort of
endorsed FTX and caused people to trust
it wrongly I'm sympathetic to that
frankly I'm a VC we didn't invest in FTX
because they were an offshore brokerage
we looked at the early rounds I have
those pitch decks yeah because they're
an offshore brokerage we thought there
was no way they could come on Shore
legally they had the ftt token which we
thought was an unregistered security
which would cause some problems down the
road
and they had Alameda trading on the
exchange I was looking back at my old
email trail from LPS why didn't you
invest in FDX you got the look what are
you doing you missed this huge deal we
told them exactly that there's no way in
exchange in the US would be able to have
a proprietary trading firm owned by the
same entity trading exclusively on the
exchange that would not be allowed and I
guess it's worth hammering home the fact
that you know FTX was was exposed at a
moment when a company that was going
thinking about buying it said ah you
know what we're not going to do this
because we don't trust it I mean the
market on some profound level the market
weren't to expose a bad company but so
like what do you think what do you think
happened there because you know there's
presumably some pretty smart people at
Sequoia and these other big investors
why did they miss what you were seeing
pretty clearly
different approach to risk tolerance
um and also
um they the deal Dynamics I mean in 2021
remember hottest time Venture Capital
history I'm sure the deal was moving
extremely fast this was the fastest
growing company in the industry in the
hottest industry on Earth for Venture
dollars so the power would have been
totally on the side of the founders and
not on the side of the VC so I'm sure
they understood they needed to do less
diligence this will come out in the
court of law eventually what happened in
order to win the deal and they thought
that that was a worthwhile trade-off I
mean it wasn't just FTX where this was
the mindset among VCS it was very common
back then
you you know you you mentioned
could you also you you had said there
were three things that
um the crypto uh world could be doing
and just to get back to this one of them
was doing due diligence like investors
doing due diligence do you remember the
other two uh yeah so for just to
summarize the first thing VCS aren't
just VCS their stakeholders aren't just
their LPS they're stakeholders are
everyone and when you're investing in
these exchanges that have hundreds of
millions of clients globally your
stakeholders everyone that uses crypto
because if you fail you'll bring the
regulatory hammer down which is what is
happening now so VCS need to understand
that
um two proof of reserves it's a very
obvious thing
if there had been approved reserves in
place which is basically a procedure
whereby an exchange or custodian
demonstrates that they have reserves and
then they compare those to their client
liabilities and they show they match
that's cryptographically provable it's
technically very doable quite a few
exchanges do it already
if FTX had done that obviously they
wouldn't have been able to commit fraud
if proof of reserves had been normalized
throughout the industry FTX wouldn't
have been able to do it assuming they
were in this parallel universe they were
doing fraud and they would have been
sticking out like a sore thumb so if
that was normalized throughout the
industry
these insolvencencies FTX Mount gox
quadriga they would be really evident so
that is a very simple thing I'm pushing
very hard for it you'll actually see
legislation Texas introduced a bill
asking for it I think that'll pass
that'll become part of the
self-regulatory framework that is used
in the industry and it's a very positive
thing unfortunately we're too late now
and the only reason it's got so much
uptake is because of FTX
the third thing is just building better
decentralized exchanges such that we
don't have a Reliance on centralized
exchanges that's also happening so the
technological Trends here are very
self-regulatory as far as I can tell
you with regards to the
um the proof of reserves question you
know I I want to play this little clip
from uh Gensler the the video that he
put out after the Kraken action uh that
has been uh kind of circulating
especially among uh what you might
describe as the Bitcoin maximalists I I
want to play this and get your reaction
because they are saying that this this
validates the view that uh you know it's
it's Bitcoin and self-custody are the
only way to go um so let's just play
this real quick and get your reaction no
not your keys not your crypto you see
you're basically an investor in their
platform if it goes under and we've seen
plenty of that recently you end up in
line in the bankruptcy court that's why
it's so important that these companies
and platforms comply with the secure
foreign
so you know it's the point there is that
uh you know Gensler is you know quoting
the famous not your keys not not your
crypto line and that is kind of uh
validating the idea that you really
shouldn't even have your your crypto on
an exchange uh if you want you know
total security and sovereignty what do
you make of that Nick
yeah I mean I agree obviously you know
we invest heavily in startups that help
people self-custody their coins so I
clearly support that crypto only works
if people have some self-custody because
otherwise we give all the power back to
the intermediaries and we haven't
accomplished anything because then the
government can co-opt the intermediaries
and use them as they will
however I'm also pragmatic and I
recognize that exchanges will exist
there's demand for their services we
can't do everything in a non-custodial
way
um so there and there's a whole set of
allocators that will need centralized
touch points to custody of their coins
to trade on them Etc the decentralized
infrastructure isn't the totality of the
industry and it will never be so in my
view the challenge is to improve the
exchanges that do exist and pressure
them to be as accountable as possible
which is why I'm an advocate of proof of
reserves for instance
regarding like whether it validates
Bitcoin maximalism I mean staking can be
done self-custodally can be done on your
own even there's actually you know
Services allow you to stake if you don't
want to stake yourself you still kind of
retain access to your coins but you're
relying on a more sophisticated pool
that will help you do it which is not a
Securities transaction in my opinion
Kraken may have left themselves open to
that allegation in terms of the
structure of I think that is I'm
actually sympathetic to the SEC in that
particular instance but there's
certainly ways to stake even as a retail
individual who's not very sophisticated
about the technology or anything there's
ways to Outsource that to others which
don't render it a security so I don't
see it as vindicating Bitcoin maximalism
you know in in either direction or or uh
yeah so it you know staking ultimately
will be more decentralized by virtue of
the fact that Kraken is out of the
business of doing it uh just a comment
from Bitcoin motorists writing in from
YouTube saying I just buy Bitcoin I
don't stake should I care about any of
this and I mean I guess the answer is if
you don't own your if you don't own your
keys or you don't have your keys you
should be worried about it regardless of
whether or not you're staking right
I think you should care that the SEC is
harassing the exchanges
um a lot of people you know that may
think that they're totally insulated
from that they still have some Reliance
on an exchange as an on and off ramp we
do need these touch points with banks
and with the you know traditional
Financial system we'll always need that
we don't have a perfectly peer-to-peer
economy of Bitcoin that I'm not even
sure that's really possible so yeah I
mean I'm concerned that the SEC is going
after a kraken in particular has been
one of the most reputable and successful
exchanges
um and you know I'd be concerned if
they're going after coinbase too even if
you don't agree with everything coinbase
does or everything Kraken does we still
do need these credible intermediaries
you said that you you do have some
sympathy for the SEC in in this
particular Kraken case and you also
mentioned earlier that you you know part
of the red flags with FTX for you was
that they were offshore
presumably that the red flag was that
they're not complying with U.S
regulation so you know what are the
Realms that you see regulation being
appropriate for the crypto space and
where should they just the government
just be you know completely hands off
yeah great question I mean I don't think
that
um a no regulation world is is the best
because clearly the crypto industry has
failed to self-regulate I think you
could ask exchanges to do proof of
Reserve
um that's similar in some ways to
um having oversight uh over uh you know
I I would say it's actually more of a
substitute for a really aggressive
top-down uh regulatory stance
um I think asking exchanges to segregate
client and operating capital in an
accounting and a literal sense
um is completely the right way if you
look at nydfs they had guidance recently
that they published asking for that
segregation asking a privilege client
deposits in the case of liquidation I
totally agree with that
um you know it doesn't make sense for
clients of exchanges to be really
subordinate Junior creditors in the case
of bankruptcy they're you should have a
trust style product in the name of the
client such that they're insulated in
the case of bankruptcy or something like
that so you know those are really Common
Sense things that I think should exist
aside from that I think um
you know I well other domains were
regular regulation is warranted would be
a kind of a Securities Law framework
where we allowed to bring Tok we were
able to bring tokens into concert with
Securities Law through some disclosure
framework that was fit for purpose the
way we have a disclosure firmware for
equities the things you need to disclose
are different so we will need a revised
framework however the administration is
not implied anything or suggested that
they might want to do that so that's
more of sort of a wish list item but I
don't think it'll happen anytime soon
do you oh go ahead Zach well no just on
the proof of proof of Reserve question
is the government necessary in order to
implement that sort of thing or are
there ways to is it possible to validate
that some other way
it's uh right now it's being done on a
purely discretionary bottom-up basis by
a number of exchanges including binance
they just released a new implementation
of their por and it's really
client-facing so it allows the clients
to have the confidence that the
exchanges have their coins and you don't
need the government to do it you don't
even need an audit firm necessarily to
oversee the process
um but because not all exchanges do it I
think it's warranted that the state
would actually ask them to I know I'll
be called a status for for saying that
but status you know I it's actually
really proactive and positive measure
do you um are are there places either in
Congress or among regulatory agencies
that are pushing in the right direction
or is it just overwhelmingly uh you know
over the past year there have been so
many negative uh events that the you
know it's virtually impossible to change
the kind of direction of uh the
regulatory push right now
well um Hester Percy who guessed it was
on just now obviously does an amazing
job as one of the minority members of
the SEC I think she offers a voice of
reason there an alternative voice
in Congress the republican-controlled
house is where a lot of crypto folks are
looking to in terms of Defending against
some of what I perceive as an
unconstitutional overreach especially
through the bank Regulators to redline
the crypto space so
um you know representative emmer who's
now the Whip or McHenry who's the
chairman of the financial services
committee many of us in the crypto
spacer hoping that they might be
galvanized into action here
uh in the Senate there's a few key
members as well but it's very unclear
which what the Senate stance is on
crypto and then the courts honestly I
believe that
in many cases the facts are on our side
um whether it's Securities Law whether
it's stable coins being Securities or
not which is now apparently an open
question
um I think the courts would generally
take sensible Common Sense views and so
a lot of this will play out actually I
think eventually we'll have a series of
Marquee Supreme Court decisions and um
the problem is that that just takes too
long and so if you're predicating your
business on something where there's a
regulatory prohibition you can't wait
for a favorable court case to you know
to follow your way uh yeah are there
states that uh you know obviously
certain states are better than others in
terms of regulating
um uh you know crypto and its operations
what is what are the worst states right
now and what are the best historically
New York's been the worst because they
had the bit license which was a very
restrictive
um
um basically Charter you needed to
obtain to do business there I and there
is there's no indication like I mean
like New York State and New York City
should be the world capital of
Bitcoin but there's no indication that
anybody's rethinking that right they've
gotten better their newer guidance is
good and the bit license isn't as hard
to get as it was before it was kind of a
Shakedown in my opinion before and um
the buried entry has lowered so I'm sort
of less upset at them these days
the best state by far in my opinion is
Texas Texas legislature has three
current bills regarding crypto I think
two of them pertain to Mining and one of
them as I mentioned pertains to exchange
credibility
um
so uh you know what's interesting is New
York is the center of gravity for crypto
in the US even despite a bad regulatory
regime what about what are they doing
with uh Bitcoin mining at this point is
there any movement on their attempts to
kind of ban proof of work Kathy hokel
signed
um the after sitting on it we thought
she was going to desk veto prior to the
election after the election I guess she
didn't need that anymore so she signed
their moratorium on
vertically integrated Bitcoin mines
which is not that doesn't cover all of
them in New York but it's the start and
I'm sure eventually they'll ban it
outright so yeah on on the
state-by-state basis that's an
interesting phenomenon I think you'll
see quite a few blue States ban it
Bitcoin mining that is and and red
States encouraged it the way Texas is
for instance
how do you when you think about players
in the Bitcoin or crypto space calling
for regulation
how do you decipher or differentiate you
know who are actually who are the people
that are actually trying to improve
things and who are just the rent Seekers
because this was like an issue with this
was an issue with Sam Beckman Freedom it
was possibly a major part of his
downfall is you know we pulled up this
tweet when we were talking about him
before from the CEO of binance who
ultimately was the person who blew the
whistle that started the Cascade and the
downfall and he said you know we won't
support people who Lobby against other
industry players behind their backs and
there's you know this deep suspicion and
I think very warranted within the crypto
community of uh any Financial regulation
whatsoever but you are saying that there
is some prudent regulation do you have I
don't know a rule of thumb or are there
red flags that you're on the lookout for
when you hear people in the crypto space
talking about regulation
yeah I mean the first thing is Qui Bono
right I mean look at what SPX was
lobbying for it was basically to allow
themselves to get a regulatory blessing
to come on Shore and operate a spot and
derivatives Market under the U.S Aegis
um and they were like they were lobbying
against D5 so like it was very clear
that they were not good actors in that
process and I and many others are
immensely relieved that their efforts
were stymied I think we were actually
very close to them achieving that kind
of regulatory capture in DC especially
with their weird proximity to the SEC
which I think still needs to be
investigated and there are IEX
acquisition so it was very clear in that
case that they were not operating in
good faith generally the rule of thumb
would be are you supporting the core
crypto ideological principles which have
to do with allowing self-custody
you know transactions that are occurring
outside the Ambit of the bank system
right so that's very core thing do you
support Financial privacy
self-determination basically freedom to
transact do you support cash the
properties of cash right in a digital
context that's what stable coins are
that's cash that settles finally
instantly with no settlement risk
whatsoever and where you don't have to
ask permission you know children's act
do you support non-custodial more
complex transactions like defy to the
extent you're doing that I think it's
fine to engage with Regulators in the
state but if you are
trying to improve your understanding in
the industry at the expense of those
principles and those ideologies then you
know that's when that's when there's a
problem
yeah I mean this will you know I know
we're getting near the end of our time
so this is kind of like my last question
for Nick and then I'll let you wrap up
with him Nick is like what is
um the that this idea of digital cash
being you know one of the fundamental
propositions of cryptocurrency uh what
is for people who might be watching this
who are curious about cryptocurrency but
they're not steeped in it like you are
could you just make the the big picture
case for why you think this industry is
thriving and or you know why it's grown
so much in a relatively short span and
what is the like what's the point of it
what why is digital the idea of digital
cash good and necessary and why is
decentralized finance
um a good thing well there's two main
things that
um two main Trends basically that crypto
people a broad tent are fighting against
or trying to restore one is there's a
sound money contingent so basically
believing that we should reinstitute a
monetary system that has less discretion
and so that's a rebellion against the
waves of credit that are created with
basically discretionary monetary policy
that's a long discussion of course so
that's a big part of it
the second is a push to restore
transactional privacy that has been
eroded since really the 70s since
Finance was digitized
that's and since um you know
intermediaries have been more empowered
and there have been a specific number of
legal cases especially the third party
doctrine that meant that Financial
privacy has been effectively eliminated
in the U.S and a lot of us identify this
as a very dangerous trend
and they're trying to push back at it so
defy and stable coins and of course
Bitcoin are attempts to restore
something which we once had which was
Financial autonomy and the freedom to
transact without asking the state for
permission
um uh final question uh what's the uh
state of concern that you have over
Central Bank digital currencies and um
are they moving forward in a way uh
obviously governments are going to try
and confuse people to say oh this is
digital cash
um obviously it's it's a very distinct
you know alternative to actual Anonymous
or mostly Anonymous cash what's going on
with Central Bank digital currency uh
formation that's worrying you the most
right now in the US I'm not too worried
about it thankfully
um the FED has actually pumped the
brakes on it a little bit
um I think people are they recognize
that it wouldn't make sense to
disintermediate the bank sector and just
install the Federal Reserve as a retail
facing Institution
so not too worried here overseas in more
in countries with you know fewer
protections for individuals I expect it
will be implemented obviously we see
implementations in China but thankfully
I think the US is is wide awake to the
the risks and the issues what about the
EU because I've read a couple of reports
over the past few weeks that the EU is
uh seriously thinking about it do you
think that's a place where kind of like
the U.S where people will kind of back
away from it uh for a variety of reasons
I think it's more likely to happen in
the EU
um I mean certainly than here but is I
mean is it the type of thing where China
can kind of force a central bank digital
currency whereas if you're living in a
more democratic country or one with a a
longer tradition of some level of
nationalism or autonomy it might be more
difficult yes absolutely but um in the
EU they're already going cashless in
many countries there's less of a
tradition of cash if you look at some of
the nordics almost entirely cashless
yeah and they've just passed the
sweeping framework covering crypto which
basically bans stable coins and they see
stable coins as a competitive threat to
cbdc so that should be the canary in the
coal mine where you see stable coins
banned that's when there's a desired
Institute of cbdc that is it's kind of
amazing if it happens in Europe too
because the euro is you know like a new
relatively new phenomenon when you think
about monetary history and how hard it
was to get that implement
after centuries of you know
individualized or nationalized
currencies yeah so is it just a
fundamentally more collectivist place
and a more fertile breeding ground
Fridays like cbdc's
well we are going to end it there we
have been talking with Nick Carter do
check it follow him on Twitter at
nicknic underscore Carter and read his
uh peace operation choke point to 2.0 is
underway and crypto is in its crosshairs
at pirate wires uh Nick where else
should people follow you
um all my work is on my personal website
Nick Carter dot info so you can find
everything there thank you so much
thanks Nick thanks guys
and Zach we will uh I guess we're
calling it a uh a moment right now too
so whereas Joe Biden would say we're
putting a lid on this and uh we will see
you uh next week assuming we wake up in
time unlike uh unlike Joe Biden thanks
everyone